if we look at our first big question
what's the effect of our civilization
which is required for Freud from a
philosophical perspective of your
logical perspective religious people
will argue well with a thing called
original sin I was also more enlightened
or writer's perspective which will zoom
in you in nature and what is it that you
would argue concern me as human beings
and that we apparently do not learn the
lessons or that we can turn back into
the morgue arc zone of you alive well we
do have certain dualities in front of us
that will become very important in the
next decades how do we deal with
identity identity politics differences
unfortunately in today's world because
there's so much fear there's so much
anxiety and I'll not belittling anxiety
I'm an anxious person myself how can I
be little other people's anxieties but
anxieties something we need to talk
about and when politics is guided by
anxiety or fear that's very dangerous so
one of the primary questions or problems
as I see it is this illusion that
sameness will bring safety people
started thinking that if we are
surrounded by similar people like-minded
people if we have a communities based on
sameness that will bring us safety
that's an illusion that's not the case
at all we're far too globalized so what
is happening in one part of the world
affects someone in a
different part of the world the
unhappiness of one individual in
Pakistan affects the life of someone in
Canada this is the world we're living in
so we do have to understand that we're
all in this together as global souls as
well as citizens and we need to revive
that energy of humanism and coexistence
how can we live together with our
differences around shared common values
for me one of those the main common
values one of them is definitely
democracy and definitely women's rights
because how can you have harmony and
peace when half of the world is being
pushed back into the private space I see
this everywhere in the Middle East in
Turkey as well but all around the Middle
East particularly more and more women
are being reminded of their roles as
mothers caretakers more and more women
are being pushed from the public space
into the private space into their homes
and there's a huge imbalance you know
all the Mystics throughout the centuries
have talked about the importance of
balance we have to balance energies at
the moment I think the balance between
masculine energy and feminine energies
completely broke many parts of the world
doctor is a problem for me but isn't
also a part of this is that I mean I'm
very that you bring up the Mystics they
are pinned down in our date world and
people who speak most likely are
intellectuals who are confusing people's
might concerning same as a revival of
nationalism evil all do you have mr.
Boris Johnson we can make a wholeness of
highly educated intellectuals who allies
it's the form of the portrayal of
intellectuals and how to deal with that
where is that responsibility of
intellectuals come in our society where
they are not accepting their
responsibility
worse when they are perceiving people I
think we need to differentiate two
things we can criticize the
intelligentsia the literati and that's
fair enough but at the same time have a
lot of respect for the intellect and try
to cultivate that and this is what i see
lacking we don't have enough
intellectual platforms where we see
people from completely different
backgrounds different cultural ethnic
backgrounds but also different
disciplines come together listen to each
other we have been far too
compartmentalized and I see that as a
problem because we have things to learn
from each other and I think the world
right now means more interdisciplinary
dialogues you know so I don't know how
to respect for the intellect and for the
role of the intellectual which is one of
the interesting dynamics for me because
in the UK the world intellectual doesn't
have very positive conversations as you
know but I think it's important to
comment on on what's happening in the
world it means that we care about it and
we need critical minds societies can
only move forward through critical minds
however we should also bear in mind that
there is an amazing bulk of literature
about neuroscience the brain we have
defined the intellect in only one
particular way that also needs to change
there are different kinds of internet
there's emotional intelligence as well
which we need to put into the picture
and you can only cultivate that through
stories storytelling empathy you know
the ability to put yourself in the shoes
of another person that also needs to be
in this platforms in these intellectual
platforms so it'll it doesn't
necessarily mean you know one particular
way of looking
things through logic and reason it can
be done in very different ways intuition
is also very important I think we have a
lot to learn from ancient philosophy we
have a lot to learn from each other our
reading lists need to be eclectic we
need to read from the east and the West
you know from people who are different
than us and only that diversity is going
to hopefully give us a new boost and a
new energy to move forward